i have been such a fan of this gentleman
for so many years
please welcome the host of a late show
with stephen colbert the stephen colbert
hello i don't how do you have an
audience i don't understand i'm so
jealous that you actually have people
clapping and applauding what's going on
well it's funny that you should ask
actually
um it's our crew and you want to say hi
to stephen
would you would you like to hear my crew
[Applause]
i got two old guys in here
[Laughter]
well i wish you could be here on this
set with us
it looks fantastic you're bathed in gold
and light i i love
i love your background i saw a wide shot
while i was waiting to come on the show
i saw a wide shot i love your background
it's very like
very high you know high hollywood tv
1970s i love very
merv it's very johnny i love it i mean
listen sin you know take a look at this
i wanted to show you a little
groovy shot over here um there you go
i like it already that's nice six
stephen colbert's isn't enough
[Laughter]
can i ask you a question yeah i'm asked
a question are you making paper mache
why do you have so many newspapers in
front of you you look like uh the mother
of a third grader about to make a pinata
and it's true we could um because i just
figured
i think it's um in some contexts
i always wonder why is there nothing on
that desk
because my desk at home is a complete
you-know-what show
and it's uh of all the detritus
and things that i don't i don't actually
know what drew i don't know what
what you have something on your desk i
mean most desks are
i have a bone i have a i have a bone
with my name carved in it
this was a bone that i found in my
brother's uh yard when i was a child
it's a cow bone i'll have you know
before anybody sends forensics i have a
cup
i have my phone and i have this what is
this
it's a leather coaster that's it
i love the way that you have
religion um in your show because it
shows that it's a part of
who you are and it's in the stained
glass and
the essence of it is all around but
like most things um you know
you you don't seem to press it
upon people um there is a
a statement you are making a truth you
are telling without
saying this has to be your truth is am i
correct in that yeah sure sure no i i
mean i'm not
i don't purposefully include anything in
the show i just talk about the things i
know and i care about
and obviously also my writers and my
staff and my producers but uh
yeah no i don't want anybody to be like
me i i don't always want me to be like
me so i wouldn't want to press that on
somebody else
well that's a good um segway if you will
and that's what i do drew
oh i love a good segue
um what persona
character is the most like you
in real life is it colbert
is it the man who is hosting
the late night show i guess this no this
is me the old guy was kind of like a
confession
of my uh insecurities
and also my sort of um i don't know
appetites anybody may have if they just
gave into their ego completely
if they just gave into every indulgence
like i have to be the most important
person i have to be the thing that
everyone's about i can never be wrong
you have to love me all of those things
are always kind of nagging at
at least my mind that sort of like it's
it's like a confession of weakness the
old character all these
indulgences of selfishness
that you your your psyche is always
asking you to give into and the great
thing about the old show is that i could
piggyback
on his desires and his ego and pretend
they weren't my own
but really it was just a mask he could
wear to confess and and i think people
maybe
recognize that in themselves and maybe
that's why they didn't consider him a uh
i can't use the word on daytime but um
it's it's um not
a nice part of your body
[Laughter]
um it's a chris evans um
[Laughter]
yeah poor chris evans poor chris evans
so handsome and fit i feel so sorry for
it
do you miss that and nope not at all
i don't miss that at all i like being me
i like being me
this is this is so much better hey
they'll show i didn't have the greatest
band in television john baptiste and
stay human
the old show um i couldn't actually
sometimes you just gotta come around
even the little mask that you wear as
the persona of a host and come around
and just speak directly to the audience
especially
when things are particularly dark like
they are right now
it's the the brightest thing or the way
to fight against the darkness is
actually just to speak honestly about it
and try to make a human connection
because that's really mostly what i just
want to do is just have some sort of
sense of community with my audience
[Music]
you